diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert von
b genießen sie cremige rezepte mit der
camembert cremiger genuss seit 1922
[Musik]
nicht nur dass gruner virus geht weiter
um auch die angst davor
im moment ist das virus und überall
große veranstaltungen sollen abgesagt
werden wir sind alle gefordert jeder und
jede einzelne sich die krankheit die
eigentlich dem takt vorgibt der blick
auf die europa karte zeigt kaum ein land
das noch keinen fall welt vor drei
wochen habe ich mit den dreharbeiten für
diesen film begonnen wir wollten
dokumentieren wie sich das virus auch
auf unsere ganz persönlichen
lebensbereiche auswirkt zu diesem
zeitpunkt hätte ich mir nicht träumen
lassen dass corona unseren alltag in
kürzester zeit weg damit sie mir mit dem
strich war wie steht es dann sicher
werden wir uns jetzt defizit muss der
stelle wo situation sei anders ist es
für geschichtsbücher
wenn du plötzlich immer nur der ältere
mit ist für mich schwierig
17 personen ich wurde überrollt von den
geschehnissen sowie das ganze land eine
chronik der eskalation
[Musik]
es ist der fünfte märz in der ganzen
schweiz werden großveranstaltungen
abgesagt das konzert von patent ochsner
in bern darf noch stattfinden
ich mache mich auf den weg um zu schauen
ob sich die leute ins private und stelle
fest noch ist die stimmung unbeschwert
zu unbeschwert aus heutiger sicht die
ersten warnungen sind noch nicht
angekommen beim publikum
es gilt ab sofort die bestimmung nur
noch 1000 personen dürfen ins lokal
der veranstalter steht täglich in
kontakt mit den behörden
ihm ist klar dass es eng wird durch aber
die wirtschaftlichen folgen sie noch
geschätzt
natürlich
[Musik]
auch dominiert die festlaune heute
wirken diese bilder wie aus einer
anderen fernen zeit
verkauft wurden 950 tickets nur 200
personen sind nicht gekommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
verhängt sie der box war
die realität ist umgekehrt eine woche
wird patent ochsner noch spielen dann
kommt das verbot das bierhübeli muss wie
unzählige andere lokale schließen
[Musik]
das bonner virus verbreitet sich schnell
nach einer woche sind bereits 100
menschen in der schweiz infiziere
gestorben ist heute eine 74 jährige frau
im kanton waadt fan zahlen der korona
infizierten in der schweiz haben sich
seitdem verdoppelt 210 fälle hat das
bundesamt für gesundheit mittlerweile
ist ab sofort gelten neue
verhaltensregeln social dichtern sie auf
den straßen merkt man kaum etwas davon
sind wir alle zu leichtsinnig ich bin
unsicher
die journalistische distanz fehlt mir
zunehmend schwerer
bereits sind desinfektionsmittel überall
ausverkauft das gibt mir zu denken man
nachweist arzt ich habe ihn gebeten mir
ein steril um aus seiner praxis
mitzubringen
[Musik]
es ist ein intensives momentan 100
prozent das ist natürlich relativ
[Musik]
entspannten aktiven sport sehr
realistisch und entspannt
gefährdete menschen sollen unnötige
kontakte vermeiden in stoßzeiten keinen
uv benutzen kleinkrieg nun droht ältere
menschen und wer pendelt der soll
stoßzeiten meiden neunter märz dieser
zug ist sonst immer voll langsam wird
eine veränderung im öffentlichen lebens
sichtbar übertrieben oder sinnvoll
ich bin unterwegs zu einem interview
termin in kämpft um vom wissenschaftler
antworten zu bekommen
eine antwort bekomme ich schon im taxi
im radio ist nur noch corona virus
corona videos corona virus alle haben
paul ii
alle haben angst sie bleiben zu hause
sie gehen nicht mehr aus es ist fast das
ende der welt die wissenschaftler sollen
sich an die arbeit machen und ein
medikament entwickeln die christen
sollen beten dass die krankheit aufhört
alle müssen etwas machen
der epidemiologe maßen salat hat schon
früh drastische maßnahmen und
flächendeckende tests zur eindämmung von
corona gefordert manche stimmen war
finden da schwarzmalerei vor
diese stimmen sind inzwischen verstummt
sind leider laufen mit
schreckensszenarien konfrontiert
politisches außergewöhnlich und will sie
auch uns trifft und ich glaube das ist
vielleicht ein bisschen das schweizer
aufschreckt will muss nicht tagtäglich
der vor betroffen dass unseren teams
moskito strache und man könnte an
malaria sterben und jetzt mit kubica hat
plötzlich interessierte situation aber
sehr schade und ich glaube das löste
schreibstil ist vor der wahl des ortes
das heißt für sie persönlich das sind
auf die wissenschaftler daran dass man
schwach betroffen ich glaube jeder wo
die krise miterlebt
das macht dass wir die rede ich glaube
gut früher oder später montag der moment
wenn er oder sie realisiert dass das
passiert jetzt was man jetzt quasi das
heißt sie haben also einfach im stil vor
es ist immer einfach ist immer verlass
ist szenario womit sich über jahrzehnte
lang überlegt hat mit einer pandemie von
einem virus verbreitet dass kein
gegenmittel gibt
wir sind jetzt drinnen oder 220 schütz
version und ich glaube im moment ist es
unabhängig arbeitet sie und sie denn
nicht das ganze eigentlich relativ
sachlich gegenüberstehe uns auch okay es
ist gottes nimm darunter sägen wir
hoffen dass es gott sondern es geht
jetzt muss ich die black okay was wir
sind jetzt die stimme ausnahme wir haben
jetzt schlimmste abfahren muss ich mir
quasi als gesundheitliche situation ist
sehr ernst der fall und das ist ja das
was mir wissenschaftler sind woche
einfach kommunizieren
aber es ist nicht das hollywood szenario
oder wenn es im parlament
das ist eine ernste situation aber doch
eher temporale situation aber niemals
mit so einem mit so einige bilder
konfrontiert sie es liegt wirklich jetzt
an uns dies auch zu managen so gut wie
möglich
der wissenschaftler berechneten verlauf
von pandemien voraus und ich greife
immer deutlicher dass dieses winter wir
uns auf meine eigene realität schon bald
komplett verändern können
italien ist seit heute morgen ein land
im ausnahmezustand per dekret dürfen nur
noch apotheken und lebensmittelläden
öffnet bauwesen bis zu totaler esche
bilder aus den spitälern der lombardei
in norditalien sind alarmierend china
war weit weg italien nicht als
journalistin bin ich permanent online
haben wir bald schon zustände wie in
italien zehnter märz ich besuche meine
nachbarn in seiner hausarztpraxis
täglich viele anrufer alle verunsichert
wie kurz der gebühr
ich fühle mich irgendwie eingeschränkt
also ich fühle mich wenn ich so in der
freiheit irgendwie auch eingeschränkt
klar
also es ist schon beängstigend finde ich
macht unruhe
man denkt schon viel darüber nach wie
ist das so mit kind und den großeltern
und soja darum gemacht
mit dem topmodell bloß keine hand geben
yvonne hat das was momentan wohl jeder
vorstellen
wieder schlug bei war jedes haus war
küsste verunsichere einfach gelöst
glücklich mit dem strich glaube ich
stehe jetzt dann das ist es viel ich
glaube ich im sterben und da bin ich
ganz fest gesungen die zu beruhigen wir
sterben
die hauptfrage stubsi co population
übertragen
du bist noch kein risiko gruppen ein
ich kann die größe
gesund das chronische herzkranke
bescheidener fiel er zeigt mir die
improvisierte isolationsstation für
verdachtsfälle
seit heute dürfen alle ärzte und
ärztinnen testen und natürlich immer
noch einmal wird man dort platz im
ortskern fährt aus der ortschaft strich
machte der markenwert und natur und
einmal die mit dem patienten besprochen
was ich hätte mal innerhalb von zwei
tagen
dann habe ich ein patient sei es
positive und erwartet dann die h&s waren
teils zuvor stand das zweirad wieder
schick das möglichst schon kurz nach
meinem besuch trifft die korona welle
auch in der praxis von tobias herold ein
[Musik]
positiv auch sehr gut
es kommt noch auf uns zu ein notstand
ich beginne meinen veränderten alltag
auch mit meinem handy zu dokumentieren
der verlust der normalität ist
anstrengend ausgleich hole ich mir seit
jahren in meiner yoga gruppe im schnitt
sind wir 12 schülerinnen und schüler
[Musik]
aber heute ist fast niemand da ich kann
nur schwer abschalten corona ist überall
die art und weise unseres zusammenlebens
ist weltweit in frage gestellt das haben
wir alle noch nie erlebt
[Musik]
solche nähe heute schon völlig undenkbar
sehen wird ebenso ein exil lebt jeder
stunde im wengert und ich anfordert
stunde nachrichten über q sms vorschüler
webseiten sicher mitnehmen
sie hat angst und wenn da plötzlich
immer nur der eintritt ist für mini
existenzrecht schwierig sie hatte sogar
die fotografen
also ich meine wenn jetzt plötzlich
kreis gerne mehr filme denn also
sicheren monate mit wenig wirklich
anlaufen die früchte zu findet haben
jetzt werde sie sind angst vor der
ansteckung
es ist angst vor der angst gespürt was
war heute los zuerst ich begreife dass
jede sache mit sich selber beschäftigt
ist und sich selbst und versuche also
der eigennutzung tolle gastgeber bis
aggressiv
abgemacht
aber was was man jetzt über krebs
problem dass so ein glück
du bist doch aus der
unterhaltungsbranche wir einfach 34
größere projekt ist so ibm
erstausstrahlungen generalversammlung
hanns hatt ja so alles stadion dimension
und das ist aus momentan ist oder
wirklich linie zürich fährt und wer
schon immer aber wenn mich sehr für das
mini teams liquiditätsprobleme rennen
unsere dass ich heute nicht genau wie
schwer das zu wäre zu während sie punkte
rechnet stehen wollen soviel gewinnen
wie man damit umgeht momentan als
rabbiner nicht genau sagen
er schießt sind derzeit für sas der
hunger wurde denn so wichtig
juli also was wir da noch nicht wissen
es wird so weitergehen corinna muss ihre
yoga schule schließen und wird online
kurse anbieten und ihr freund verliert
alle aufträge
das virus hat schnell die wirtschaft
angesteckt im kleinen wie im großen
viele fürchten bereits die große
rezession corona mit zum stresstest für
die ganze gesellschaft
elfter märz ich besuche meine nicht die
leoni sie studiert medizin an der
universität zürich ihre fakultät wurde
geschlossen
th zwar ist ihr ja wisst situation
kommen wir jetzt unsere sich die vorjahr
verpasst weil ich mit rock scott kommt
koste spanier sagen will ich bin ich
immer gern vor lassen sich werde der
relativ geschlossen hatte
und das ist tatsächlich die kollegen und
die mich so unterstützt ist ja wenn mich
ein mädchen machen sich jetzt hat
einfach so dass mit der politik ist das
mit dem pott kostic armee sein dass
dinge trimmen
was hat das mit krieg immer noch mit der
schon seit jahren wie medical seine
patienten kontakten geht sich einfach
fertig kornmann ist alles ok und jetzt
hin und wollte seine crew installiert
dass ihre population ist kümmert ich
weiß nicht ob sie vielleicht zum 6 je
nachdem wie setzen sie leoni lässt sich
bald schon als freiwillige auf eine
liste setzen um das spitalpersonal zu
unterstützen was wir da noch nicht
wissen das virus wird noch vor abschluss
dieses films auch in ihrer familie
einzug halten
ich besuche das universitätsspital
zürich
dort wird jetzt alles um gerüstet für
einen starken anstieg der korona fällen
leere hörsäle auch hier und ist mit dir
vor billiger über streaming zu stellen
das ist dass das wetter gerne wäre ich
da sich traurig für euch dass mit ihr
hörsaals um ihn zeige welche schicht der
eislage drin
viele medizin studieren der wollen etwas
tun und haben sich für einsätze gemeldet
thomas rother führt mich zu
improvisierten schulungsräumen sind oft
oder ehemaligen intensivstation für
china das sich so schwer und das haben
wir jetzt gäste so oft dass man denen
baustelle auf einem acker mit der
studenten damit sie ihre skills können
trainieren wirklich ganz ohne begrüße
ich ganz harmonie beste vorbereitet in
jeder koreanischen poste ich hoffe er
hat auch schon in gruppen ideal wenn die
gene fünfergruppe könnt ihr jetzt
eigentlich verboten
ich hoffe medizinstudentinnen und
studenten im letzten ausbildungsjahr
werden hier kurzfristig geschult um bei
bedarf die pflegefachleute in der klinik
zu unterstützen
frage warum seid ihr hier
was ist die motivation sich jetzt ich
glaube eine sieht es wüsste dass das
rund das ist sicher danach sieht es ja
das sieht der krone hat die belastung
fürs personal ist und ich auch im
unterstand sachse haben dass wenn mich
und das team extrem viel machen wird und
dass man da auch entlasten kann
und dann sieht sich so extrem kurzen
länder führen ich glaube ich kommt
reallife
[Musik]
was mir das auge das macht weil das
akustische das revidierte die maschine
und die zellen die das machen wir
natürlich der ganze schwere
lungenentzündung
das könnte sie meine oma virus habe zum
bespiel genau und darum bat mixa hat das
miteinander aller werke genau der
patienten schwere lungenentzündung und
er wird mit dem derartiges gerät
geordnet so pflege arbeiten die sonst
kaum ärztinnen und ärzte übernehmen
[Musik]
die idee für diesen berufsübergreifende
kurs kommt von der ärztin stefanie klemm
singt sie kennt das konzept aus dänemark
wir haben eine freitag den antrag
gestellt dass wir dieses projekt auf
gleisen wollen haben über das wochenende
habe ich das konzeptionelle gebracht
haben uns montag getroffen und haben am
mittwoch mit der schulung bekommen was
auch immer das ist der vorteil von der
situation genau die entscheidungsfindung
sind kurz gewesen und das was sie wollen
ist und ich glaube das ist das was
auszeichnet das wird nicht nur hier am
unispital zu sein so dann einfach dass
die leute bereit sind sich einzubringen
wie die bedeute auch mit einem
wahnsinnigen enthusiasmus wieder mal ein
ziel die studenten sich
eigenverantwortlich bereits organisiert
haben
die flexibilität die die an den tag
legen von allen seiten ist einfach
unglaublich ist wirklich eher positiver
hört und in dieser zeit unglaublich
diese studierenden müssten sich
eigentlich auf das staatsexamen
vorbereiten
ihr engagement berührt mich aber ich
realisiere in diesen minuten auch dass
der ernstfall tatsächlich wahrscheinlich
ist
gemüse damit rechnen dass die weltweit
massiv steigen zwei weiteren todesfällen
ist die zahl der toten in der schweiz
auf insgesamt sechs gestiegen
dort durfte intensivstation
das virus ist auch in meinem privatleben
omnipräsent respekt vor dem virus
scheint angebracht oder nicht panik oder
hektik das virus wird sich weiter
verbreiten so lange bis ein impfstoff da
ist knapp schottes filmstandorts das
sollte also ich find so dass das ist ja
so groß wird das ist auch
unkontrollierbar und fiktion heimlich
was tut man wenn jemand im eigenen
haushalt panik politisch interessant was
macht mir dass sie alle
schreckensszenarien zu ende denken tue
das weil bei panik das denken
steckenbleibt beharrt das gegenüber auf
dem schwersten szenario dass es
alternativen denken als angehöriger
hilft umarmen und festhalten
bei kindern nennt man das bären umarmung
angst richtet sich immer auf die zukunft
zurück auf den boden kommt man durch
basis mäßige körperliche dinge spannend
das machen wir aus so jetzt das machen
mit dem motorrad ich solle mal clubszene
was ja wirklich mal seit größe produkt
wo muslime gibt und zwar
die größte airport die bohne
wenn wir nochmal ich glaube das macht
die sache
wir haben keine not fahrrad für schwere
zeiten dass menschen hier samstag ist
uns fremd
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich jetzt bin ich erst wenn
die nahrungsmittel gehören schweden
sondern problem mit zukauf vor dem ende
zwei notiert manche leute haben schon
viel früher vorgesorgt
[Musik]
im schweizer ferienort ziemlich okay
okay
doch die sache so schwierig wie das
geschafft dass ich mir unterschrift ja
was sowieso da
das ist super so blickte so paul
zeitbereich ja natürlich noch immer in
der lage ein glück wenn die moto2 die
wahl krieg erwartet und die head vor
und solch ein gebiet geführt
denn otto von bismarck von not vor
rot-rot sammler und da ich dann die
jahre hin gewachsen oder fairtrade
produkte haben die tories und teigwaren
übrigens auch das sehen denn 250.000 und
laura linney in pulverform dass ich
jetzt dienstag lag das format mit wasser
und dann hat man tolerieren
das ist die sache jetzt ruft macht so
was sagt dann ihre frau fängt ja sagen
dort staut sich wollte am anfang ist der
pizzeria und betrieb schnitt und sie man
weiß nie und dann aber vielleicht ist es
fehlen nicht
nein weil das was ich in der stetige
rotationen in der food weist gibt es bei
uns eine übrigens
dort das laufen in eine leere stelle und
fragt sich jetzt lieber daheim seine
bürger bichsel mit kawasaki spaghettini
sich alles da wir den abschluss und
gültig ehrlich gesagt und schienen mir
sogenannte preppy immer etwas seltsam
aber er hat nicht planlos das
beeindruckt mich dass ich jetzt so
genannte haus kraftwerk dadurch mit der
ganzen strom vom dach oberhand
der nachteil ist attraktiv
alles läuft sind sie eigentlich von
einigen häufig hurrikane seid ja ich
doch nix kosten oder wo meine aufgabe
lange lange schnitte und plötzlich ist
jetzt was los gang mit dem kronos need
to sehn ob und wie es weitergeht und ist
man gar nicht nein das wissen wir nicht
manche menschen geraten in panik und
verhalten sich irrational
die migros hat eine
informations-offensive lanciert um die
leute zu beruhigen
es ist ganz wichtig sind meilenweit
entfernt von einer schweren lage oder
das neueste video aus gaza die lager
sind gut gefüllt aber für den nachschub
ist gesorgt dass planung sieht kaiser
machen uns hier und da sie das risiko
die kurzzeitige kurzfristig vergriffen
sind aber es ist möglich die er die
logistik und alles was dahinter steht
klar verpasste
in zeiten von corona ist der austausch
an der kasse bereits etwas unangenehm
bald wird bargeld aus dem alltag
verschwinden
die angestellten sind der gefahr direkt
ausgesetzt werden aber instruiert die
dame desinfizieren und schon wenige tage
später gehören bei den grossverteilern
hygienemasken und plexiglas scheiben
sondern normalität für jeden
lebensmittelbetrieb wäre ein corona war
katastrophal
der geschäftsführer der confiserie
bachmann in luzern hat sich gewappnet
und eine wärmebildkamera angeschafft
fieber messen ab sofort obligatorisch
bittet neigen sie aus und legen sie
bitte wenn vorhanden ihre brille und
kopfbedeckung kurs ab hinzu tritt wird
gewährt bitte bitte liebe sie auf der
markierung stehen
hinzu tritt wird gewährt bitte gehen sie
sodann ausgeführt
und jetzt könnte ich ihnen zeigt was
passiert ist er über temperatur wie
heißt das wasser und würde es nochmal
den strudel auf
bitte bleiben sie auf der markierung
stehen legen sie bitte wenn vorhanden
ihre brille und kopfbedeckung kurz ab
die gemessene temperatur ist so hoch der
zutritt zu weiteren räumlichkeiten ist
ihnen schritte und
danke für ihr verständnis flexibel jetzt
gerade davon glaube so etwas habe ich
diese e mails sms oder telefon und dann
wird über die person abfall wasser und
hygiene schleuse da gab es dafür sei das
nicht dann können wir die handtasche das
mache gerne dass die krone
das tool das licht seines bruders
mittelbetriebe werkstor
desinfektionsmittel zur seite genau und
den gang in die aktuelle produkte
wir haben verschiedene gedanken gemacht
wie man meinen könnte wählen können und
zeigen dass wir mitarbeiter schützen
georg rips instrument das möglich und
abbau und sonders natürlich hat es mit
dem betrieb wenn du kannst ist das
einfach sich jetzt noch schnell
es ist sehr schwierig sie also in erster
linie will ich sehr lang als manager das
letzte modell überwiegend wie in europa
verfügbar ist und endlich eine sahara
was hier genau ist will das sind pro tag
über unter musik und ich möchte mit der
zirkulation und schüler nicht nur
mitarbeiter die das hinterhof handwerker
das sind tagsüber wenn man sich mit der
für zulauf und das sind die fragen dazu
den spielgerät mit den tieren in kauf
und installation der wärmebild anlage
hat bachmann rund 20000 franken
investiert andere camus haben inzwischen
kurzarbeit anmelden
das kroner virus trifft mit voller wucht
die wirtschaft des virus macht auch
zunehmend dem tourismus einen strich
durch die rechnung in der schweiz keine
touristen die whu spricht jetzt von
einer pandemie und mir scheint kaum
jemand kann richtig einschätzen was das
bedeutet fakten und spekulationen ohne
pause die zahl der infektionen steigt
rasant was heißt das für uns
ich gehe nochmals ans universitätsspital
zürich
aber heute überlege ich mir zum ersten
mal ob ich wirklich noch den bus nehmen
soll
im osz gegen die ersten corona patienten
und es werden wohl noch viel mehr werden
in den spitälern sind die
intensivstationen gefordert noch dürfen
wir hier filmen
da ist die schließlich war eine
schlüssig und dazwischen ist thema
welches detail wo man sich um zu schauen
was vor auch das ganze material sie
masken haben diesen entschluss ist mir
dann so weit wie 1030 schutzbrille
wowereit man muss sich fragen ob sie
hätte gar nicht nachvollziehen ich
wieder und trinkt sie war mit ruß ist
jetzt zu viert oktober erwartet dass sie
noch ein zwei woche durch fragen sie den
skill die botschaft jetzt mit dem
wirklich abstandhalter mit den
infizierten ist schon weniger usa und in
der eu was uns wie haltet aber nicht
unter das thema wieder predigen und
versuche das ganze team darauf
aufmerksam zu machen dass das ist ganz
wichtig und das hat viele junge leute um
empfehlungen lied oder schaufel
symptomatisch vertrag sie und aus witten
und familie aus stecke die high und
wahrscheinlich wird das bewusstsein zu
rücken ausstiegen und plötzlich eigene
familie mitglieder betroffen sind dann
wird sein bewusst aber das sport und ich
weiß jetzt ja ich meinem herrn der
kopfhaut ausstiegskurs oft könnten im
moment geht sie waren sehr steil würde
das heißt mit dem gesetz trophy richtete
dass man einen kuchen aber voller
prozent an die ein zwei drei wochen
nebenan wird ein stillgelegter intensiv
trägt wieder in betrieb genommen
das ist jetzt eigentlich die
vorbereitete die intensivstation wenn es
mehr prozente
um wieviel sorgt die genaue btz die
werden 16 plätze so einrichten dann ist
einseitig frei das wären acht schutz für
sie als erste mal dass sie es mit einer
situation konfrontiert sind ja das ist
glaube ich für viele das erste mal was
heißt das für sie persönlich das ist
eine interessante und gleichzeitig etwas
beängstigende situation natürlich wenn
man nicht weiß was genau auf einen
zukommt und womit sie rechnen dürfen
manch einer sieht es bei der patientin
traktoren aber anders sieht haben
natürlich auch und das eigene soziale
umfeld um genau wüsste man eltern und
großeltern wie gross denen wir sind die
situationen sind sehr belastende
situation und das ist aber dass anleger
dass man jetzt nur noch der schichten
versuche wenigstens debriefing zu machen
untereinander das muss mir gott uns als
team
die task force des osz kommt auch an
diesem tag zusammen
sie muss ständig reagieren die lage
ändert sich praktisch stündlich
die stimmung ist unglaublich angespannt
ein besucher stopp beschlossen und
umgesetzt innerhalb weniger stunden eine
drastische maßnahme
das geht sehr viel geht wo gerade noch
nicht so mit mit ideen überlegen wir
auch für die wirklich schwedische
brauchen dehrn iv sommer sehr viel
prozent weiter vor rivale entwertet will
im moment ist übersichtlich und das ist
ethisch vertretbar gef denken sie
station dass er heute bei viertelstunde
2 x 6 meter ein vordergrund denn erkläre
die überlegung wo man im moment machen
das ist völlig für die zweite vier
wochen vorbereitet sind
wird unser gesundheitssystem standhalten
werde ich krank was ist mit meiner
familie ich bin permanent am handy die
informationsflut ist zermürbend
[Musik]
die angst wird größer ist mit diesem
ausnahmezustand auf längere zeit
umzugehen
vielleicht hat der therapeut antworten
auf die nagenden fragen die viele
beschäftigen
gibt es eine möglichkeit der panik zu
entkommen also da wieder aus dieser
diese spirale herauszukommen also wenn
es keine rationalen angst ist die gesund
ist dann geht es vor allem darum erstmal
zuschauen was es überhaupt die ursache
bin ich vielleicht zu wenig informiert
also weiß ich nicht weil sich nicht
genau was der chor ohne virus ist wie
ich mich davor schützen
da ist natürlich informationen keine
angst kann auch entstehen wenn ich fast
schon über informiert bin also wenn ich
links und rechts versuchen so viel wie
möglich informationen zu finden
vielleicht auch bei weniger seriösen
quellen kanälen kenner also ich muss
nicht stündlich wissen was gerade
abläuft ich muss nicht stündlich wissen
wie viele neue infizierte gibt es aber
ich kann vielleicht einmal am tag mich
aufgelaufenen bringen mal schauen muss
was die medien sagen aber eben
vielleicht push-benachrichtigungen
deinstallieren oder oder blockieren so
dass ich nicht einfach die ganze zeit
neue meldungen die vielleicht angst
auslösen sind bekomme aber natürlich ist
die ist die erwartung angst auch da also
was wenn es soweit kommt und das ist
auch das ist auch eine einer der gründe
warum ich mich in einer angst rhein
steigen kann weil dieses was wäre wenn
natürlich unendlich weiter gesponnen
werden kann
ich kann mir das stoppen quasi dieser
gedanke der nicht zu ende gedacht wird
macht angst wenn ich im konkret werden
lasse und mehr möglichkeiten überlege
wie ich damit umgehen kann dann habe ich
mehr kontrolle über die situation und
das beruhigt
[Musik]
dahinter märz eigentlich wollte ich ja
einen film über over to reason machen
die region zb war immer übervoll mit
asiatischen touristen
[Musik]
jetzt sind die reisegruppen verschwunden
nichts ist mehr wie vor corona nirgends
die umwälzungen sind kaum zu fassen
ich habe mir einen newstead verordnet
muss meine gedanken sortieren durchatmen
da dachte ich noch dass dies ein schönes
bild für den film sein könnte aber nein
noch einmal überschlagen sich die
ereignisse
[Musik]
der bundesrat verschärft die maßnahmen
die pandemie ist ein gültig angekommen
in der schweiz weiter an schulen wird es
am vierten april nicht mehr unterricht
und bis ende april sind verstand und
über 100 personen verboten
die wirtschaft stehen zehn milliarden
franken als soforthilfe zur verfügung
auch bessere fährt ausnahmezustand meine
kolleginnen und kollegen im newsroom
arbeiten unter zusätzlichen druck
besonders sendungen und das sind
wirklich super die idee kommt sondern
was für monate je nachdem
also diverse länder in die zeitgrenze
dicht gemacht und als beispiel wurde
schnell allein darüber die total hat
es gibt so viele fragen rund um das
virus gesundheitliche fragen wirtschaft
droge bewegungsfreiheit vorher meinten
es wird jetzt immer dramatischer und
insofern für eine news andic geht es gar
nicht dass sie man hoffe es ist nun
pflicht nur wer unbedingt muss kommt ins
büro alle schulen sind zu abertausende
von familien sind gezwungen ihren alltag
neu zu ordnen
auch die familie meiner kollegin mona
vetsch dort eine schule haben wir
erfahren dass mir für mich zwei wochen
am stück werden und was ist passiert
schrecklich fehlen dadurch die wesen 18
ist muss ausbruch was ist das genau
gemacht was wir also schon geplant macht
was er will
der market dome am vormittag in ihre
arbeitsblätter uhr spiele durchaus
eigentlich deine sachen gemacht die
erträge wird ich habe schulfrei und ich
finde es ist cool mit grad aber die
jungs noch am gleichen tag folgt der
nächste paukenschlag
der bundesrat hat heute entschieden die
situation als außerordentliche lage zu
erklären bleiben sie zu hause
vermeiden sie kontakt mit anderen person
ich fahre nicht mehr tragen und nur zum
drehen sind wir gemeinsam unterwegs
wir fahren nochmals ins
universitätsspital nur eine woche ist
seit unserem ersten besuch vergangen
aber die lage hat sich völlig verändert
zufällig treffe ich vor dem eingang auf
intensiv pflegefachfrau lazzarotto sie
wirkt bedrückt die welle von quellen sei
jetzt da
[Musik]
was für ein albtraum für einen moment
kann ich dir angst nichts mehr
entgegensetzen
hoffentlich hält das spitalpersonal
dieser belastung stand ich warte ab
peter steiger
das schafft somit sehen jetzt dass es
massiv erzielt also das heißt sie
gestern seine fabrik und stege die
prozentzahlen exponentiell jetzt 1000
das sind vorbelastet
ja also nahm er an der patienten körper
wirklich sehr sehr wenig vorkommen zum
beispiel bluthochdruck und schwindel auf
der intensivstation gestorben ich zum
glück niemand pauschal prozent machen
das nierenversagen
die meisten machen die mit beteiligung
von der a7 auch herz entzündung und sie
wache sehr langsam auf nach themen die
ganze schlafmittel stoppt
was ist ihre größte sorge wir haben die
größte sorge dass personaler frank werth
will das ist die große angst wenn man
nur bereit und cupholdern ist die
patienten
was wäre japan ab bevölkerung ich bitte
jetzt einfach chronische erfahrung krieg
hat und jeder wahlmann auch das oder
flac heimischen zur risikogruppe gehört
der patient dafür wirklich zu machen
damit für uns ganz klar ist eine
intensivtherapie überhaupt gewünscht die
schwierige situation sollte man alles
machen oder wie immer das berührt mich
wie die bevölkerung ihre wertschätzung
für das gesundheitspersonal kundtut
gleichzeitig denke ich noch besser als
klatschen wäre mehr lohn für diese
wichtige arbeit genau drei wochen sind
seit beginn der dreharbeiten vergangen
und die welt ist eine vollkommen andere
ich hoffe dass wir die entschleunigung
die solidarität und die menschlichkeit
hinüberretten in die zeit nach grüner
[Musik]
die krise wird sich in unser kollektives
gedächtnis einprägen und alle müssen
einen weg finden sich dem neuen alltag
anzupassen
[Musik]
home office verfügt es sei jetzt stehen
wir alle in der verantwortung
diese sendung wurde ihnen präsentiert
von dr genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
der camembert cremiger genuss seit 1922